for an expert full presentation on how
the bio info platform can be used or
leveraged for genomic analysis so as i
was mentioning before the break the
platform the omics logic platform is
designed to help you
um
is designed to help you learn more about
these analysis methods and their
applications in various project examples
so the program in particular that we are
going to uh that we are going to present
will include many more expanded overview
of the key concepts principles and
examples of genetic genomic data
analysis and mentor support and
and all the associated uh
all the associated uh credentials to
perform these analysis
so how
so let's move on to how are such genomic
studies used in real life let's move on
to the applications
of these genomic studies so what kind of
research questions do they answer and
what is the application of such an
extensive analysis of genomic data so we
will discuss few examples today and few
example applications of genomics and we
will find that the applications of
genomic studies can be employed to
characterize genomic variants or
inherited genetic variants that can
cause deadly diseases like sickle cell
anemia and that can cause mutations in
oncogenes that may cause cancer and that
can cause variations of mutations in
specific gene that might cause or that
will cause huntington's disease or that
will
cause several mutations or variations
which will eventually enable a pathogen
to develop resistance to the drug that
is used to kill them so first
upon receiving the dna sequence of a six
sick patient the first question we
generally ask is what genes are
different what genes are affected but
due to the volume of the sequence and
due to the number of variations that one
usually finds in sequencing output
analysis this is not a simple and
straightforward question to answer even
though genomics is currently being
employed and used for diagnostics in
clinical care purposes many dna variants
are still being discovered and are still
being annotated and are still being
rigorously analyzed by researchers and
by scientists from diverse teams so for
example in cancer the dna variations can
help us to determine the genetic risk
associated with the oncogenes but most
often oncologists will look for somatic
mutations in tumor suppressor genes in
onco genes or in
dna repair genes specifically since
cancer most often occurs with age many
researchers see the accumulation of
mutations in key genomic area
genomic regions these accumulated
variations will occur as a combination
of driver mutations that causes the
cancer and passenger mutations that tag
along with the driver mutations and
identifying such mutations and
variations in these key genomic regions
can help us diagnose cancer very early
on or can help us evaluate the risk of
the cancer severity and to help us
well
eventually point is to select uh
appropriate treatment that will slow
down
incurable
metastatic cancer situations so one
example is um
for a gene in particular p53 tumor
protein p53
which is responsible this protein is
responsible for tumor suppression so it
is implicated in many cancer
that this
gene prevents tumor growth through a
process called apoptosis so some
mutations in these genes that are
characterized some mutations in these
genes can lead to loss of function
ultimately promoting tumor genesis by
not controlling the replication of cells
with the damage to dna so
this is an example from cancer yeah
those are the mutations and other
diseases like cystic fibrosis can also
be linked to individual genes like the
ctfr gene which can uh which can affect
the function of a channel that is
responsible for clearing the mucus from
the airways and hence um
cystic fibrosis is born
and
in in the case of huntington's disease
which there is an inherited condition
there is a genetically inherited
condition from parents or from uh
from
from
chromosomal combinations where a
specific gene on chromosome 4 has an
abnormal number of cag codons that is
repeated so this htt gene encodes large
a very large protein called huntington
protein and the additional repeats in
this gene will will change the structure
of the protein resulting in
movement disorder and resulting in
dementia and resulting in behavioral
abnormalities so in around 2015
the huntington consortium published an
excellent study of over 1 000
individuals with early and late onset of
basis the genomic analysis and targeted
sequences and whole genomic sequencing
whole genome sequencing of this
data
of this analysis uh
from this analysis the researchers
discovered
important regulatory mechanisms that are
different between these two groups one
group which develop early and one group
which developed late on set of basis so
this study also identified okay let's go
back yeah that is a
yeah that is this one this study also
identified important mutations as shown
here in chromosome 15 that are to be
associated with the slower development
of clinical onset so this research as
well as others are excellent examples of
how genomic studies and extensive
genomic studies can help us identify
mechanisms of disease progression and
help us identify potential therapeutic
interventions using the natural
mechanisms of disease regulation so
in another example tuberculosis is a
contagious infection that usually
attacks lungs
it can also spread to other parts of the
body like brain and spine and bone etc
a type of bacteria that you all know
called mycobacterium tuberculosis causes
it but the severity of this disease is
very well known and
it is still one of the leading causes of
deaths over all over various countries
today most of the cases are used cured
with antibiotics however recently this
bacteria has become more and more
resistant to single types of antibiotics
it turns out the resistance is a result
of mutation on specific genes or
specific promoters so understanding
which genes and which promoters that are
involved in in developing this
resistance to antibiotics and the
mechanism of this resistance development
are
very critical and crucial to develop new
drugs and to
identify a multi-drug resistant
tuberculosis infection from which
patients can be easily uh
saved so
in in a
in another uh
example that relates to current
situation viruses are extremely prone to
acquiring mutations because of the
number of times that they replicate
themselves and
the limited machinery that they have in
proofreading the replication process so
the ebola virus for example is an rna
virus that causes severe disease with a
very high mortality rate during the
outbreak that happened in 2014 and 16
the genomic sequencing efforts has been
applied in near real time
real-time
track
to understand and to
to model the pandemic spread and to
develop a vaccine as a result many
researchers focus their attention on
potential mutations that can have
profound effect on vaccine efficacy as
well as viral transmission rates this
happened in 2014 and 2016 but we are
seeing actually
uh we are saying that
a similar track that is uh untraveling
for sars kobit 19 virus the efforts in
characterizing the characterization of
different variants and the efforts in
understanding the efficacy of multiple
different vaccines that we have in our
hand so
so in this workshop
today we reviewed the fundamentals of
genomics as well as the bioinformatics
tools and the applications of such tools
to various research clinical industrial
challenges and we demonstrated you uh
how to perform such analysis in tbio
info platform i hope
this
workshop and such uh
and today in
a session today will help you in
appreciating the concepts the data and
the analysis method that is using
genomics to learn each and every um yeah
to learn
more about each and every one of these
steps in detail please subscribe to the
genomics program that is starting
shortly and i will be happy to take any
questions if you have and please present
your questions in the chat room
and that that will conclude today's
session thank you all for participation
and waiting for your question